[Müzik]
herkese Merhaba Hoş geldiniz
şimdi sizden özellikle ricam %100
continuasyon ile bana odaklanmanız çünkü
112 yıllık köklü bir üniversitenin
Yıldız Teknik Üniversitesi'nin
sahnesindeyiz ve lütfen unutmayın bu
sahne ezber bozanların sahnesi Şimdi
sizlerle birlikte bir başarı oyunu
oynayacağız ve yine ezber bozmaya da
devam edeceğiz bozacağımız ilk Ezber
ilk defa bu sahnede sizlerin tercihi ile
birlikte sunumun akışını değiştireceğiz
ve birlikte bir kararlar vereceğiz
ardından ise maceranı kendin seç
konseptini deneyimleyeceğiz maceranın
kendini seç konseptini bilir misiniz
daha önce kitapların belirli bir
sayfasına geldiğiniz andan itibaren
yazar size bir tercih yapmanızı ister ve
o an verdiğiniz tercihle birlikte
kitabın sonuna farklı şekillerde
ulaşabilirsiniz 30 sayfaya geldiniz bir
tercih yaptınız 54'e veya diğer
tercihinize bağlı olarak 64 sayfaya
gidebilirsiniz daha sonra bu
teknolojinin evrimiyle birlikte dijital
platformlara kaydı yine aynı konsept
Murat Keskin hizmeti veren bu
platformlarda sinema filminin birine
geldiğiniz andan itibaren size bir
tercih yapmanızı sundu ve o yaptığınız
tercihle birlikte bu akış yine değişti
belki senaryonun akışını değiştirdiniz
karakterin hayatını değiştirdiniz işte
Tam burada ikinci bozacağımız ezber var
ilk defa yine bu sahnede Bizler de
maceranın kendin seç konseptinde Yapay
Zeka yardımıyla birlikte kararlar
alacağız
Şimdi sizlere Alya ile tanıştırmak
istiyorum
Alya hayatındaki dönüm noktaları için
bize danışacak ve interaktif olarak
Yaptığımız bu seçimlerle Alya'nın Hayat
hikayesine birlikte tanıklık edeceğiz bu
yolculuk 4 dönüm noktasından oluşacak ve
bu 4 dönüm noktasında birlikte bu başarı
oyununda ihtiyacımız olan 4 anahtarı
birlikte yakalayacağız bunları
anlatırken benim de hayatımda
yakaladığım bu anları o anda yaşadıkları
ile birlikte sizlerle paylaşacağım ve bu
Yapay Zeka karakteriyle birlikte
kararlar vermiş olacağız şimdi bütün bu
dönem noktalarını nasıl şahitlik
ettiğini ve kariyer yolculuğunu simüle
eden bu Yapay Zeka arkadaşımız Alya'nın
ilk bölüm noktasını gelin birlikte
dinleyelim
Herkese merhaba ben Alya kariyer
yolculuğumda bana eşlik edeceğiniz için
size ve İsa'yı Şimdiden çok teşekkür
ederim
zorlu bir sınav döneminin ardından mezun
olarak üniversite sınavında iyi bir
derece elde ettim bu derece ile
prestijli üniversitelerin birçoğunu
tercih edebiliyorum lise boyunca hem
Mühendislik alanlarıyla hem de beşeri
bilimlerle yakından ilgiliydim Bana
dünyayı daha geniş bir perspektifte
anlamamızı sağladığı eleştirel düşünme
ve iletişim becerilerimi geliştirdiği
için beşeri bilimler artık çok daha
yakın hissediyorum Bunlar birçok
sektörde kullanabileceğim değerli
beceriler ve geleceğim içinde farklı
kariyer yollarını seçebilme özgürlüğünü
sağlayabilir Tabii ki Peki ya sen ne
düşünüyorsun Nisa
Evet ne kadar heyecanlı ve bir tercih
yapması gerekiyor ilk dönüm
noktasındayız şimdi bu tercihi birlikte
yapacağız ve ben size bir tercih
yapmanızı rica edeceğim Bunlardan ilki
az önce de bahsettiği üzere bir mühendis
mi olmayı seçmeli veya bir sosyal
bilimcinin olmayı seçmeli olacak şimdi
el kardanarak bana bu noktada Yardımcı
olmanızı rica edeceğim Sizce Alya
mühendis olmayı mı tercih etmeli Lütfen
bu tercihi yapanlar el kaldırabilir mi
teşekkürler Peki ya sosyal bilimci
olması gerektiğini düşünenler
teşekkürler
ekseriyetimiz mühendis olmayı seçtiğini
görüyorum ve Mühendislik kararını verdik
Ve artık mühendis bir alyamız var Ve
bundan sonraki akış mühendis bir Alya
üzerinden devam edecek ama burada neyi
fark ettik bir karar vermemiz
gerektiğini fark ettik ve bu kararı ne
kadar önemli olduğunu ben de hayatımda
yaşadığım şu anıyla fark ettim Mimarlık
eğitimin boyunca sıra arkadaşlarımın çok
ciddi el becerileri vardı ve çok
yetenekliydiler müthiş tasarımlar
yapabiliyorlardı ve eskizler çok iyiydi
hocaların her birinin çok hoşuna
gidiyordu benim ise böyle bir yeteneğim
yoktu ve o anda karar vermem
gerektiğinin Bir Ana şahit oldum ve
el becerilerimi geliştirmem gerektiğini
mi yoksa kendi hayatında keşfetmem
gereken bir başka özelliğim olduğunu mu
düşünmeye itti ve yöneticilik
kabiliyetlerimin daha gelişkin olduğunu
fark ettim ve eskiz el çizimlerimin
üzerine giderek orada alacağım Bir özel
ders yerine yöneticilik alanında kendime
daha fazla geliştirmem gerektiğini
düşündüm çünkü güçlü yanlarımı daha
fazla güçlendirmem gerektiğini hissettim
ve o anda verdiğim kararın bundan
sonraki Hayatım boyunca benim aldığım ve
yaptığım ve o sorumluluğu üzerinde
hissettiğim kararları bütün hayatım
boyunca sürdürebileceğimin o ilk anını
Yaşadım ve bu sorumluluk bilinciyle
yaşamam gerektiğini fark ettim ve bundan
sonraki yüksek lisans ve doktora hayatım
onun yanı sıra kariyerimde elde ettim
hiç tecrübelerinde geldiğim nokta
tamamıyla o an aldığım o karar ile oldu
yani yönetici olmayı seçtiğim o an o
özelliğimi geliştirmeyi seçtim o an
bundan sonraki kariy erimi de
şekillendiren şey oldu
ilk dönüm noktamızdaki birinci
anahtarımız irade doğru iradeyi
gösterdiğimiz ve bu sorumluluk bilinci
ile sonraki hayatımızda da bu
sorumluluklarını üstlenebileceğimizi
hissettiğimiz o anda olması gereken en
büyük yetenek irade şimdi
birinci anahtarımızı artık cebimizde ve
Alya'nın hayatındaki gelmiş olduğu
ikinci derin noktasını birlikte yine
deneyimleyeceğiz Alya'nın hayatının
tercihlerinizin sonucunda nasıl şekil
aldığını ve bir sonraki dönüm noktasında
size hangi konuyu danışmak istediğini
yine gelin birlikte öğrenelim
çok mutlu ve başarılı bir üniversite
dönemi geçirdim aynı zamanda sosyal ve
mesleki anlamda birçok fırsatı
değerlendirdiğimi Düşünüyorum şimdi
geleceğimi belirleyecek çok önemli bir
eşlikteyim bu süreçte arkadaşlarımla
bize heyecanlandıracak bir fikir üzerine
çalışıyorduk ama alanımla ilgili iyi bir
şirketten yeni mezun olmuş birine göre
kazançlı bir iş teklifi aldım şimdi
düşününce bir iş kurmanın stresi ve
ekonomik belirsizlik yaşamak yerine iyi
bir şirkete dair olarak kendimi
geliştirmeye daha fazla
odaklanabilirmişim gibi geliyor sen
olsan hangisini tercih ederdin
fark ettiniz mi Yine Bir dönüm
noktasındayız ve bu anda yine bir karar
vermemiz gerekecek Bunlardan ilki
mühendis Alya'nın kurumsal bir şirkette
Çalışmayı mı yoksa kendi iş fikrinin
Hayata geçireceği bir startup kurmayı mı
tercih edeceği olacak şimdi Bu ne yine
birlikte karar veriyor olacağız Sizce
Alya kurumsal bir hayatta kalmayı mı
tercih etmeli bu seçeneğin sunanlar
lütfen eğer Kaldırabilir mi
teşekkürler Peki ya startupta Kendi iş
fikrinin hayata geçirmesi gerektiğini
düşünenler O starta bayağı ağır bastı ve
bundan sonra mühendis Hala kendi İş
fikrini Hayata geçireceği bir startupa
sahip ve bu anlık verdiği karar aslında
şu oldu Bundan sonraki hayatı boyunca
kabiliyetlerine ne noktaya
taşıyabileceği ile ilgili bazı kararlar
alması gerektiğinin artık farkında ve
irade koyması gerekiyor Bu iradeyi
koyduktan sonra ortaya Star tapın da
çeşitli noktalarda farklı deneyimler
yaşayacağını da biliyor beni mesela
Hayatımda bu şöyle oldu mezun olduktan
sonra yüksek lisans eğitimimi yeni sıra
aynı anda büyük bir startup kurmama
karar verdim ve büyük bir restorasyon
işe aldım ve Hayatımda ilk defa
tercihimi
özel İhtisas gerektiriyor ve
kapalıçarşide büyük bir restorasyon
işinin içinde buldum kendimi teklif
verdim ve işe aldım ardından ise bunu
nasıl gerçekleştirmem ile ilgili
danışmam gerektiğini fark ettim mühendis
ve Mimar büyüklerime gittim beni bu
konunun uzmanı olan bir başka arkadaşına
restoratör bir mimara yönlendirdiler
hemen kapısını çaldım sabah erkenden
beni karşıladı ve bana bütün bir gün
boyunca restorasyon işine ait detayları
anlattı şantiyeye götürdüğü tarihi bir
yapının restorasyonunun içinde bulunduğu
bütün detayları anlattı Ben de ona şu
soruyu sordum ve benim bundan sonraki
hayatımda isteyecek bir mesele de sahip
oldum dedim ki bana bu kadar neden
yardım ettin abi yani bunu niçin yaptı
herhangi bir bedel de istemedim O anda
bana şunu söyledi İsa ben şu an sana
yardımcı oluyorum sana ricam odur ki sen
de senden sonra gelecek Tüm bu genç
arkadaşlara mutlaka yardım et ve onların
gelişimi için destek ol birlikte
büyüyelim oldu ve o anda aslında şu
andan geriye dönüp baktığımda
bir ikinci anahtarın ne olduğunu fark
etmiş oldum ben eğer ki staj hayatım
boyunca Etkin iletişim kurarak kendi
mentörlerimle birlikte o Etkin
dinleyerek onlardan bana katmaya
çalıştığı her noktayı detaylı bir
şekilde özümseyerek hayatımda tecrübe
ederek ve doğru iletişimimi kurarak
doğru insanlarla tanışarak o Etkin
iletişim becerilerimi yönetişim
becerilerimi geliştirdiğim noktada bir
işte ilk tecrübeyi dahi elde ediyor
olsan bile bir mentörün Bana Destek
olduğunu fark ettim ve sosyal
sermayemizi şu sıralarda oluşturmamız
gerektiğini ve bu sosyal sermaye ile
birlikte bir Network erişmemiz bu
Network Etkin kullanmamız ve bu Etkin
networkün ise bize daha sonra ciddi
kapılar açacağını fark etmem gerektiği
oldu ve böylelikle Aslında ben insan
Kütüphanesi oluşturmaya başladım ve o
kütüphanemdeki ilk insan Yani ilk kitap
ise o mentörüm oldu ve bugün hayatıma
devam ettirdiğim müthiş bir özelliğe
sahibim ve ikinci anahtar kelimesinin
ise hayatın ikinci dönem noktasında
olması gereken en büyük anahtarın
iletişim olduğunu düşünüyorum
mühendis bir ailenin irade gösterdiği ve
Etkin iletişim becerilerine sahip
olduğunu düşünüyoruz ve bu özellikleri
elde etti Şimdi ise bu özelliklerle
birlikte Alya'nın hayatında
tercihlerinin sonuna geldiğimiz 3 dönüm
noktasındayız şimdi onu dinleyelim hep
birlikte
sizlere çok güzel haberlerim var En son
görüştüğümüzden beri evlendim ve şimdi
ilkokula yeni başlayacak Bir kızım var
Ayrıca Uluslararası bir kariyer için her
gün daha fazla çalışıyorum yani Gün
geçtikçe hem Kariyerim Hem de özel
hayatımda sorumluluklarım artıyor
Bazen aileme ve arkadaşlarıma daha çok
zaman ayırmam gerektiğini hissediyorum
ama sonuçta kızımın bu yaşa kadar
büyütebildim ve yıllardır birlikte
olduğum dostlarımla her fırsatta
görüşebiliyorum işime daha fazla
odaklanarak ekibime liderlik etmek
kendime meydan okumak ve sektörümde
önemli bir iz bırakmak istiyorum Bu yolu
seçersem çevremdeki herkese daha faydalı
olabileceğini düşünüyorum
sen olsan nasıl bir yol izlerdim
şimdi bunu
birazcık da detaylı anlatarak size fark
ettirmeye çalışayım şu an yapmamız
gereken tercih şu; kariyer kariyeri için
hedef ve hayallerine mi yoksa
sevdikleriyle daha fazla vakit geçirmeye
ayıracağını Seçtiği bir sahnedeyiz şu an
yani şu an şuna karar vereceksiniz
kariyerine odaklanmalı diyenler lütfen
el kaldırabilir mi
Peki ya sevdikleriyle daha fazla vakit
geçirmeli ve sevdiklerine odaklanmalı
diyenler
Teşekkürler Biraz yarı yarıya çıktı gibi
ama aslında şunu içten içe hissettiniz
değil mi Tercih sunduğum nokta aslında
herkesin işten için sorguladığı ama
sözlü olarak anlatamadığı bir tercih bu
bu aslında bir illüzyon Neden mi Çünkü
ben de kariyerin boyunca çok hızlı
ilerleyebildim ve çok genç yaşta aslında
bir müthiş bir fırsatlar edindim ve
yönetici ardından müdür daha sonra Genel
Müdür Yardımcısı oldum kariyerimin
basamaklarını çok hızlı çıkmaya başladım
Diğer yandan ise bir özel hayatım vardı
evlendim bir kızım oldu ve diğer ailenin
getirmiş olduğu büyük sorumluluklar
Diğer yandan kariyerimin getirdiği büyük
sorumluluklar bu her iki büyük
sorumlulukları yaşadığım ve stresli
olduğum o anda
bir tercih yapmam gerektiğini
düşünüyordum ben de sizin gibi ama
illüzyon olduğunu fark ettiğim an şu
oldu iş yerinde çok değer verdiğim bir
iş Arkadaşımın bana hediye ettiği bir
kitap oldu bu belki bilirsiniz büyük
Panda ve küçük Ejderhanı hikayesi Bu
hikayede büyük Panda küçük Ejderhayı
kariyerinde beraber yürüdüğüm Bu
insanlarla birlikte şu önemli soru
bundan sonraki hayatında insan
kütüphanesinde olması gereken ikinci
kitap
Sizce diyor
yolculuğun kendisi mi daha önemli yoksa
varmak mı
Bunu evet düşünebilirsiniz sizde ama
burada benim anlatmaya çalıştığım şey
şu; bazısı yolculuk diyor bazısı varmak
diyor ama bence burada üçüncü bir
seçenek daha var yola kiminle çıktı bu
da bana şunu farkettirdi özel veya iş
hayatımdan birini tercih etmek zorunda
değilim üçüncü bir tercihim hep var ve
bu üçüncü tercihi bulmak için bazı
şeyleri keşfetmem gerekiyor ve bu keşfi
ise o anda yakaladım ve yola çıktıklarım
yani yol arkadaşlarım benim için
değerliydi Ben iş hayatımda
sorumlulukları aslarıma vererek iş
yüklerimi hafiflediğini gördüm yani
egoistçe bir yönetici olarak onların
kariyerlerini önünü kesmek yerine
onların önüne açmak iş hayatında ise
benim için gerçekten fedakarca çalışan
eşimin bir anlamda özveriyle Bana
kariyerimde Destek olduğunu hissetmek
benim bir tercih yapmak zorunda
olmadığımı hissettirdi ve orada şunu
söyledim doğru insanlarla yola
çıkmasaydım bu sağlayamazdım Hani
dengeyi sağlayabilmeniz için bu hayatta
irade iletişimin yanı sıra doğru
arkadaşlara ihtiyacımız var bu ailemiz
olabilir arkadaşlarımızda üçüncü
anahtarımız ise yol arkadaşı olacak 4 ve
son dönüm noktamıza geliyoruz elimizde
çok ciddi anahtarlar var başarı oyununu
kazanmaya doğru ilerliyoruz ama günün
sonunda ne olduğunu birlikte
keşfedeceğiz şimdi Gelin 4 dönüm
noktasını hep birlikte şahitlik edelim
bugüne kadar ki tercihleriniz için
teşekkür ederim bana unutulmaz bir
kariyer yaşattınız kişisel becerilerimi
tahmin edebileceğimden daha öteye
taşıyarak maddi ve manevi anlamda
oldukça tatmin olduğum bir iş hayatı
yaşadım
çocuklarım Evet torunlarımla birlikte
daha büyük bir aileyiz dostlarım ve
çocuklarım emekli olmamı hisselerimi
satmama hayatın tadını çıkarmamı istiyor
ama beni artık tanıyorsunuz kişisel
başarımın keyfini çıkarmak yerine
servetime ve becerilerimi sosyal
sorumluluk faaliyetlerini adamanın
dünyada olumlu bir etki yaratmanın benim
daha tatmin edeceğini biliyorum
Senin fikrin de duymak isterim İsa
zengin hissettirdi değil mi Artık benim
noktaya gelmiş startuplarında başarıya
ulaşmış bir mühendisin alacağı büyük bir
karar var çünkü ciddi bir sermaye var
elinde ve o anda bir karar vermesi
gerekiyor yine zor bir karar her zaman
olduğu gibi Sizce ertelediği hayallerin
peşinden mi koşmalı yoksa dünyayı
değiştirecek bir izme bırakmalı kararı
verecek
birlikte yine karar vereceğiz
erteliğini ertelediği hayallerin
peşinden koşmalı diyenler lütfen eğer
Kaldırabilir mi
Peki ya dünyayı değiştireceği bir iz
bırakmalı diyenler
Teşekkürler bu bu seviyeye gelmiş herkes
için çok ciddi bir karar ve bir sosyal
sermayenin yanı sıra ciddi bir maddi
varlığa erişmiş belli noktalarda
başarılı olmuş benim de böyle tanıdığım
bir hayatta bir ünlü yönetmen vardı Çok
yakın ve 15 yıla yakın bir süre
içerisinde birlikte çokça vakit geçirdik
bu ünlü yönetmenin bir karar anında Ben
de şahitlik ettim O ise şu oldu
ciddi bir kariyere sahip birçok turneye
çıkmış Türkiyenin dört bir yanında çok
fazla insana şahit olmuş onlarla
birlikte çalışmış bir yönetmen elde
ettiği sermaye ile birlikte o an karar
vermesini hissettiği bir anı oldu işte o
da şu kariyeri boyunca gezdiği Turna
yaptığı Anadolu'nun dört bir yanında o
kadar zeki ve o kadar Çalışkan
öğrencilerle karşılaştı ki maddi
imkansızlıklarla okuyamadığını veya
farklı çevre sebepleri ile okuyamadığını
fark etti ve onlar için bir burs fonu
oluşturmak istediğini söyledi ama diğer
yandan Bütün hayatı boyunca hep o anı
yaşamak için çalıştığı hayallerini
kurduğu bir sinema filmi yapmak vardı
zeki öğrenciler için burslu fonu mu
oluşturmalıydı yoksa hayatının filmini
mi çekmeliydi
her tercih Aslında buraya kadar olan
süreçte başka bir seçimi seçmediğimizi
fark ettik değil mi hep beraber aslında
bir tercih başka bir şeyi tercih
etmemişti birlikte bu tercihleri yaptık
Ama bazı şeyleri tercih etmedik ve o
anda yine bir seçim yine bir tercih
yapmanız gereken o anı hissettik hep
birlikte bu tüm bunların hepsinde öne
çıkan duygumuz neydi veya olması gereken
şey o aldığımız kararlarda hissettiğimiz
şey cesaret doğru Cesur hamleleri
yapıyor olmak Eğer ki bir fona yatırım
yapar ve bu Bursa öğrencilere birçok
kişinin hayatı değişecek Diğer yandan
kendi hayallerini kurduğu İşler de onun
65 yıl boyunca her gün bir sonraki gün
için geçirdiği O ana şahitlik edecekti
Bütün bunların hiç biri olmadı
o anda Neyi karar vermesi gerektiğini
hissettiğinde şunu söyledi artık
cesur bir şekilde hayatını kazanmaya
yönelikti bugüne kadar olan 4 dönüm
noktasında 4 anahtar artık cebimizde
irade iletişim yol arkadaşı ve cesaret
şu an ise herkesin fark ettiği öze Biz
aslında bu oyunun amacının kazanmak
olduğunu düşündüysek Aslında kaybettik
Çünkü bu Oyunun amacı
bu değil
kazanmayı düşündüğümüz her hamle
Yaptığımız her doğru tercih Aslında
kaybettiğimiz bir andı her tercih bir
seçme iş ve dolayısıyla bir kaybediş
oldu peki bu başarı oyununun Sizce amacı
neydi
bu Oyunun amacı kendinizi keşfetmekti
kendinizi keşfetmekten korkmayın Cesur
olun ve hayatınızın Kahramanı siz olun
teşekkürler